[Applause]
hey welcome to a new rainy project camp
update
so we basically bought this piece of
land and a prototyping a more
sustainable way of living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous updates you
might have seen
it does rain in portugal
and that we're waiting for our
containers and this
week is actually raining a lot so it's a
good time to just see
observe the land and see what the water
actually does to it
so let's start by here this
is completely flooded right now and
there's a little creek at the end so
let's have a look how full that is
maybe you remember this creek i showed
it in the second update
and back then it was raining a lot but
you actually didn't see any difference
so here's the little creek and it's not
even that much fuller
even though it rains all the time and i
was kind of amazed by that
that all the rain that fall didn't
really affect the water level of the
creek
but as you can see now uh yeah it rained
a lot and it did affect the creek
now this complete area is flooded
do you think it's a soap tree
so this water basically comes from a
stream
but it's also being amplified here by
all the water from our own land running
off
into this creek so i'm kind of curious
to see where it actually leaks water our
land and where is it coming from
and whether we can change that so the
overflow of the creek
basically is the lowest point of the
land but in order to understand where
the water comes from we kind of need to
go up
and see where the water leaks until it
finally ends up here so for instance
here you see some water flowing
and it comes up from there
flowing right there into the creek
another stream where you see the little
streams
of the road coming together here to go
to the lowest point
another stream right down there
another stream in the middle of the road
going to the lowest point
another downside of not maintaining your
water properly
it erodes the roads so sand goes down
and there's another big stream here and
it's really
deep this stream a lot of water
because it comes from this hill right
here
also a little bit of this road and then
this water is flowing down here
so this road was recently cleaned and
fixed so they put some blueish gravel
here
and the old road is still like yellowish
but now you can actually see very well
the flow of the water and the gravel so
when it rains a lot it really goes
takes all the water and the gravel with
it and in order to prevent the water
puddles on the road every now and then
you see this
sometimes made by humans sometimes by
nature
but that the water can flow away
creating these little streams
a few weeks ago a neighbor or local guy
asked if he could have a sheep
walking around on our land and this
is the result of that
looks nice
sounds different though pouring hot
water compared to cold water
so i started to document all the streams
i could find on the land into a map
so let me show you so here you can see
the land
and the blue lines are all the streams i
found so far and the bigger the line
the bigger the water flow of the stream
so it's mainly to see
where all the streams are and whether
there are all the time to keep an eye on
it and to see if there are any patterns
and maybe also it's possible to divert
some or to combine some together into a
bigger stream
so it's just to sort of keep track of
the water flows of the land
um but now i know where the water from
the creek comes from from all these
little streams
but i got curious where did these little
streams come from
because they're even flowing when it's
not raining and
we can see the top of the hill so what
is there
so i'm curious what happens if i just
follow a stream so i start down at the
creek
and go all the way up until i found the
beginning
i don't know kind of curious so i'm
gonna check it out
so right there is the creek and then you
have some water flowing from here
to the bushes which goes there down here
down here is very soggy so kind of
overflowing and water everywhere
but you can see a stream coming from
then another accumulation right there
you can see some water coming but uh i
don't know how to get there
quite a lot of water flowing here so i'm
now in the middle of these bushes i hear
the water
flowing but i can't see it so i might
have to go up a bit more to really see
it flowing
follows along the rock line
here it comes from there
[Music]
now deep into the bushes
and now we're actually at the main road
so we came from down there
the water accumulates here on the road
and also comes together
from there and from here as you see the
water coming from actually out there
we're almost at the highest point so i
guess at some point we need to see the
beginning
slowing right up
now we come to the more rocky area of
the land so the water is still flowing
here
but you can see it's already a much
smaller stream and it also comes from a
few places like here
here so slowly
fading out the stream
so let's try to follow one of these
smaller streams
[Applause]
comes from the bush right there
so now we're basically on top of the
hill and here you can see pretty well
where the water comes from
because i guess in your mind you would
like to see this big spring
or river where it flows from but it's
not like that
here let me show you
so here you still see for instance a bit
of water flowing
then if you follow it up still flowing a
little bit
as you can see there the water
go up a bit more here is
very little water flowing but some
it goes here here and then here it's
basically just
i know still water almost
and that's kind of how these things
start you just have this patch of land
that absorbs the water
and slowly releases it
creating these little streams that come
together accumulate
becomes a bigger stream it becomes a
little river
a creek and that's how all the water
flows off
the land into the little creek so you
might wonder
like what does it matter if your water
flows off your land
and because there's enough right yeah at
the moment there's an abundance of water
here because it's winter but in the
summer you would also have dry months
so you kind of want to make sure you
have enough water done and if all the
water flows off your land now
well it doesn't come back in the summer
dry months so it's
kind of important to make sure you keep
water on your land and make sure it
doesn't flow
into a creek in the river into the ocean
but really retaining the water
and just because we made it all the way
up here a shot of the view
so a good way to store your surplus of
water
is in a lake and they're basically like
a battery for your land
you can have when you're of an abundance
of water you fill it up there
and in the moment you need it you can
take it out again but as you can see
here the lake didn't really get that
much fuller
so in a way something could be improved
here instead of the water flowing
out to the creek it should first fill up
this thing
our battery and then flow of the land so
we still have some
water retainment work to do so you might
wonder why are you walking around in the
rain i thought you were waiting for the
containers to come
true and last update the roads were
cleaned however
on top of being the roads cleaned they
also need to be dry and up until now
it's been very rainy
and we need to have a few days in a row
where it's dry so the soil is not muddy
and the truck doesn't like
slip away so until then i guess i have
to amuse myself with other things
so if the roads are still not dry next
time i think you're gonna clean up that
lake which seems like quite an
interesting task
if you want to follow our updates make
sure to subscribe
if you want to see all the updates have
a look at this playlist
and if you like what we do make sure to
visit support.projectcom.com
thanks for watching and see you in the
next video